Staring at
You know wife
With the
See where your mind is so
I'm like you ask somebody cuz you are
initiator
Yes in store
Will be walking into soUntil first they
would be up to. It if you don't.
Yeah
ProvidMy world.
Today when I enter his world
So that's why
Now
Exposed to and
Yeah
It's very soft exactly
A boy scouts a football player a member of
the ROTC and honorable student he was
hanging around his teacher's classroom
Door hereWe go. Just needed the same time.
To do the school district says that is not
what they trained English teacher pause
office to do it and I didn't say it and no
one else in the class knows that I said cuz
I did interview all the time version
Trying to understand
Need help
Can you run the Specifically to you.
Old
December
I have 30 years of data on the Cowboys
Comma
He got
They have no sense of
Belong years
Real relationships surface level Ben need
external validation from men they also need
external validation From Success so if they
don't become successful they self implode
the way that they meet these needs in this
patriarchal society is Success power and
dominance we see how they're doing this okay
they are being told that they are providers
and protectors and a lot of them cannot live
up to this world okay this is not possible
for all of them because women
They don't make real friends they are
stuckDown here.
This is how they are operating this is not
safe for anyone
Period
You have the mail loneliness also this is
happened historically it never women get
more access to resources and then fall apart
control system
Have a good day
True
It's
Inside rental
Pick up the game priority today
So okay so that's kind of confusing here
because when I see the capabilities and what
I could do with it I instantly think of
maybe the agents
I really don't know
I think this is just over complexity for me
I'm already running eight agents on my main
computer I can't really justify
Anything other than the web scraping
Because running the Thea browser in non
headless mode
Has been causing trouble and then if I add
this in addition to the fact that we have
If you add this in addition to the fact that
we also have agents that will be hidden
while the chat gbt browser is open then you
see now we'll have
It's just a complicated process so if we
were to move that over to the laptop I feel
like it would be a little easier but I don't
See a personal need once we get the Headless
mode of the theater implementation running I
mean
Yeah
That's what also unlocks also allow us to
create maybe like a scheduler that automates
post into our websites and social media
possibly
This is taking too long